Murray Wathan is a senior with a 3.7
grade point average her declared majors
history and her minors or graphic design
in Spanish her career plans are as yet
undecided but at Hillsdale she takes
part in the honors program serves on the
student Federation and belongs to the
students for life club the Catholic
society and the Lyceum she also plays
intramural football to help cover her
college costs she works as a student
mentor and a student ambassador Murray
is the fifth of six children six
children three of her siblings are
post-secondary graduates and her family
lives in Lincoln Nebraska her father is
an engineer Murray
thank you dr. Whalen freshmen parents
faculty staff and administrators of
Hillsdale College welcome it is my
privilege to share a few words with you
this afternoon and to welcome the class
of twenty nineteen to this Hillsdale
College community it was a snowy
blustery night in January you know the
kind that we tend to have in Michigan it
was the night before classes began for
my second semester of sophomore year
after watching a movie with friends I
ventured out to make a short walk back
to old storm but as I was making my
final turn I suddenly slipped on a sheet
of ice and broke my leg as soon as my
body at the pavement I realized first
that it hurt and second that my semester
was going to look a little bit different
than I had expected yet I didn't have to
face the challenge alone I was
overwhelmed with an outpouring of
generosity from classmates professors
and administrators who stepped in to
help in this moment it became clear to
me that he'll still offers more than
exposure to great ideas and wonderful
classes it offers an incredible
community that will support you along
the way that community sets hillsdale
apart and I'm so pleased to welcome you
into it when I broke my leg my friends
were the first responders and my
greatest champions within moments of
receiving my frantic phone call they
moved me quite gently into a vehicle and
whisked me away to the emergency room
with friends like these who needs an
ambulance after my surgery the
transition back to campus was eased by
friends who wield me between classes and
helped me navigate the lunchroom my dear
friend Christina became famous for her
willingness to kick others off the
heritage
couches so I could sit with prime leg
elevation these tells old friends didn't
pity me or just say good luck and move
along they entered into my challenge
with me they rolled up their sleeves and
said we're here to help and we managed
to have a wonderful time along the way
we laughed we cried we talked we joked
and through it all our friendships grew
and flourished as we dealt with the
struggles of that semester close friends
became best friends and college friends
became lifelong friends their kindness
inspired me and challenged me to live
more selflessly to give more readily and
to encourage more constantly in your
next four years at Hillsdale you two
will meet individuals who will share
your joys and your troubles and become
your dearest and most lasting friends
prioritize spending time with the
awesome people known as hillsdale
college students and you will not be
disappointed in addition to my friends
the Hillsdale administration and staff
helps more readily than I ever could
have expected my house mom at olds
affectionately known around campus as
mama G was only in the second day of her
job when I broke my leg yet there she
was through my whole recovery picking up
meals driving me to doctors appointments
and even welcoming me into her apartment
as a month-long roommate by the end of
that semester I found I'd been blessed
not only with a tremendous helper but
with a mentor and a friend parents mama
G is just one example of the type of
people you are leaving your children
with and I would just like to say
they're in good hands the professor's
also came through for me in my moment of
need as soon as they found out what had
happened which was pretty soon thanks to
a collegian article i received an
abundance of concerned and encouraging
emails from professors I had that
semester professors I had had previously
and professors I had never even had in
class the head of our history department
dr. Cal Toth took his lunch hour to meet
with me in the Student Union and
reorganize my schedule so that it would
be more manageable the way professors
responded reflects the way that we think
about education at Hillsdale those
professors realize that being educated
is about more than memorizing and
regurgitating a set of facts it's about
being formed as a whole person so they
care not only about our academic success
which they do care about they want to
see us grow intellectually spiritually
and personally so class of twenty
nineteen get to know them allow them to
mentor you and allow them to share their
many and abundant words of wisdom I know
office hours can be intimidating but
remember your professors truly want to
help you will all have your broken like
moments at Hillsdale you will face
challenges that make you wonder why on
earth you signed up for this it may
happen when you receive back your first
freshman paper don't worry it's rough
for all of us or as you're trying to
sort out chemical conversions in
preparation for an upcoming exam we all
have our ups and downs at Hillsdale
because this environment challenges us
to be more than we were when we arrived
but succeeding at Hillsdale isn't
something you can or should do a loan
perhaps you can squeak by without help
from others but a Hillsdale education is
about so much more than that it's about
being formed to live a good full and
flourishing life and that kind of life
must be lived in community be assured
that the type of generosity that i
received abounds at Hillsdale so
freshman class as you begin your first
year at Hillsdale immerse yourself in
this community which will show you truth
beauty and goodness where you had never
even noticed it before
and be sure to watch your step on the
ice thank you